hi this is John Roca for Collider a back
again with Evette memorial evident
vanassa and the great Sylvester Stallone
Rambo last blood ladies I want to start
with you first please what is one thing
that surprised you working with this
gentleman here so Westar Stallone
well my fantastic surprise no surprise
because I know his work obviously is
this beautiful acting connection you
know because he is really a very good
actor you know yes and we can't discover
this from the first minute because when
the actor see you and you can see his
soul it's it's true yes it's one thing
for me was I didn't know how well he
rode horses this guy's the champ of
riding horses if its exterior but yeah
yeah I've been watching Yellowstone they
ride a lot of horses on Yellowstone and
some of the things you did in the movie
I saw if there's oh yeah that's right I
know those guys yeah they're called
rainy horses yeah right right fantastic
yeah how one of the main things that
surprised me about the movie it made me
fall in love with the movie is the very
real connection of three of you have as
this pseudo family and without it
there's no way those last 20 minutes are
as effective and overpowering and hell
yes as they are how did you two go about
developing this chemistry between each
other we got very lucky you know you
never know
I'm telling you think you can hire five
of the best actress and then they hate
each other right I tell you the truth
even on Kaplan no one talked to each
other
oh wow and I mean we do our scene that's
it Wow
you know it's just a lot of actors are
very private anyone there was when our
scenes were over with sitting talking
whatever so it's the magic is there
that's the hardest thing I'm telling you
you can't plan for it mm-hm you can have
so some of the best actors and it just
end up not liking each other or like you
said you look in their eyes you know
this
is not even active he didn't learn his
lies he doesn't care right but they all
really cared you all spend time with
each other off said just kind of getting
to know each other no no not really I
know just natural chemistry yeah on set
off set everyone had their private life
it's just what did it became business
right Oh question I want to ask you a
Sylvester how do you prep to walk back
into the boots of John Rambo because he
is one of the most heartbreakingly
tragic figures that you portray on
screen what is the prep work you do to
come back into that I start thinking
about like my early life and like a lot
of people you know you just it's not
perfect mm-hmm I find that you know
people complain at all
I'm a failure because my father was me
my mother was mean I said everyone has
those problems that's no excuse so I
start to brood a little bit I start to
become very reticent quiet alone and
staring a lot because he stares always
looking so that's I just really retreat
it's not a I'm not popular around the
house even the dog sensitive they don't
come to you really I'm it's really
interesting yeah animals are go I think
I can track your Instagram and see the
difference in your video they don't
worry about my throat what is it like
for you to to watch him go into the
character does that elevate what you're
bringing to the table does it excite you
as actresses as well in this situation
definitely I mean I think for me seeing
him just he means business so you don't
really want to mess around you want to
do your work deliver it and as much yet
but you also do want to have fun because
we are a family and we do have this
relationship where he's raised me so
there has to be a balance yeah first of
all the script and the script is
beautifully as a writer because you can
imagine this wonderful character and
this wonderful relationship the script I
think is everything
yeah I agree and I got a rep up here
because there are three hour movies that
don't have these kinds of connections
and in a 90 minute movie you found a
very strong connection with each other
that sells the movie the brutality is
going to be there but it's this that
shows the moving beam alright man thank
you so much it's all three of you that's
Rambo less blood I'm John for Collider
wash this thing you're gonna love it